okay then everybody we might as well get
started um hello thank you for coming my
name is Matt and today I'm gonna talk to
you about writing allocation free code
in c-sharp this is a topic which has
kind of got a bit trendy lately there's
a lot of thing people talking about it
there's a lot of mention on it in the
blog post on what have your food net
core and it's a good way of kind of
improving your performance by reducing
the amount of memory that you allocate
so I'm gonna have a look at a few things
we're gonna look at some stuff which is
perhaps sort of micro optimizations and
some other things which are a bit bigger
a bit more interesting such as the use
of the new span of T type and the api's
around that um but we're gonna start off
with a little bit of simple advice for
how you can write some allocation free
code in c-sharp and that is don't don't
do it the things I'm gonna show you
today
don't bother most likely you don't need
to do this there's going to be some
low-level optimizations and micro
optimizations and basically you're not
going to need it unless of course you
actually do need to do this and I can't
tell you whether or not you are going to
actually need this so basically if you
take one thing away from this talk is
this one always be measuring profile if
you need to do this you will know you
will see in your profiling results that
you need to do this you need to do
something about performance and there
are things you can do that then to
reduce performance by reducing the
number of allocations you've got but
always please be measuring don't just do
it on gut feel measure make sure you
know what what you're doing and why
you're doing it so let's talk about why
why do you want to write why would you
want to write allocation free code and
reduce the number of allocations you've
got we've been using dotnet for a good
while now and we understand that we've
got a member managed memory environment
which is great it does a lot of work for
us and it removes the need to sort of
manually handle our allocations and when
we free our memory there as we've kind
of got into our heads really the managed
memory is cheap this isn't strictly true
it's more along the lines that
allocation is cheap so it's very easy to
allocate memory but
garbage collection then there's
expensive so garbage collection itself
it stops the world it pauses everything
has to do a lot of work then to to clear
everything up compact your memory down
and the introduces pauses and so that's
really what this is all about here it's
all about throughput and it's it's about
the idea as well which you might not be
using a lot of memory but you might be
allocating and freeing a lot of memory
so your memory traffic might be very
high you might be using two five
gigabytes of memory over time but your
peak memory could sort of stay at about
500 megabytes and it's about trying to
reduce this throughput so if you're
talking about throughput the idea is
that there the more allocations mean
that you have more garbage collections
more garbage collections mean more
pauses and pauses then disrupt the
throughput and if we try and improve our
throughput then this gives us a smoother
experience not necessarily faster but it
usually does equate equate to the two
but we are smoother we're having less
pauses less interruptions and things run
smoother and therefore they usually
faster so this is good then for anything
that is sort of particularly low latency
so servers you obviously Don a garbage
collection while you're serving a page
because then the user has to wait until
the garbage collection is finished
before they see the page the same with
games you don't have been lining up to
take a shot at somebody and everything
pauses while there's a garbage
collection and then carries on similarly
with interactive user interfaces you
don't need to pause there and block it
up because you can feel it and it's it
interrupts the flow of what you're doing
and if you look at those lists as well
that kind of covers a lot of the
applications that we tend to build so
generally speaking throughput and
improving throughput is a good thing
it's also useful if you are working in a
constrained environment so if you're
working on a mobile device for example
or a console or other similar sorts of
environments using less memory is
generally it's a good thing so if you
can be more conservative with your
memory you get again reduced garbage
collections and better throughput if
you're working on a less powerful device
then your garbage collection can be
slower and also it's doing more work so
it's gonna be using up battery so fewer
garbage collections will be better for
battery life
and all this does come down to
throughput and if you think about
throughput and games again mobile
devices are absolutely huge for mobile
gaming is absolutely huge on mobile
devices and one of the big environments
for writing games on mobile devices is
unity which is C sharp base of all of
this does apply but there's another
reason which I think is very useful for
understanding all this kind of thing is
is that you should know your platform so
even if you're not actually going to be
doing this in your own code you're still
going to be using it in your in the
platform itself so one thing that has
sort of changed over recent years with
dotnet is how performance is really a
key part of the design of the platform
it's really built in so every feature
that is now being built there is always
always an eye on performance and you can
see this in some of the recent features
so if you are looking at c-sharp tuples
for example there's already a system to
pipe they could have just built it
around that but those are reference
types those would cause allocations
every time they get used so they've
actually introduced a new type value
tuple which is a struct allocates on
this stack and that is then better than
for for allocations and again for
reducing the amount of memory that
you're using you can see a similar sort
of thing with the ia sync enumerator
feature which is a a weight for each and
also in a value task which has been
introduced to work with asynchronous
programming I'll talk a bit more about
that in a sec and then of course this
this new span of T API which again I'll
talk about in a little while so let's
have a look at some some easy things
here what are the low-hanging fruit what
are the easy things we can do to reduce
the amount of memory that's going on
just kind of keeping an eye on these
things so again once we've profiled we
want to have a look at this we want to
make sure that we're doing the
appropriate things but there's a bunch
of things we can do which are very easy
to sort of fix some of these things so
we can reuse objects we can have object
pooling we can pass in pre-allocated
arrays rather than having to allocate
them all the time reuse an array once
it's finished rather having to let the
garbage collection garbage collector
clean it up and reallocate new stuff
string concatenation we all know this
one use a string builder instead of just
concatenating strings there and if
you're using a string builder you can
reuse them as well so you can combine
that with the first one there and if you
know the length of the thing you're
trying to build you can pre allocate it
as well so it doesn't have to work
around reallocating items there params
is an interesting one so we'll have a
look at our params is a good one here
because the allocation that happens here
is something that you don't necessarily
see when you're writing the code is
something that the compiler is
generating for you so you can be writing
code like on the left here passing in to
two string variables to string value
sorry or nothing at all and the compiler
is actually generating the code on the
right so it's allocating an array for
you allocating array of two string
values here and even when you're not
passing anything at all the compiler is
allocating an array for you so every
time you call there's another allocation
but it's an allocation for an empty
array except I'm lying to you that
doesn't happen on newer frameworks in
newer compilers we use the array of
empty sorry the array dot empty of T
method here which will reuse an empty
array for you so it's important to know
again this is it this is you've got a
profile you've got to know what the
platform is doing here you can't just
trust me I'm just some guy standing on a
stage don't trust me
profile and see what's actually going on
what's happening but these kinds of
things are allocations happening which
you need to work with so boxing another
useful way of reducing the amount of
allocations that happen
boxing happens when you pass a value
type to a method that expects a
reference type so you can have something
like console.writeline the parameters
they get passed into that are expected
to be objects but if you pass an integer
to that it gets boxed and when we are
boxing something that creates a new
object on the heap which is going to be
the box it copies the value type into
the that object and passes that into the
method and that means you're working
then with a copy of the value type and
any changes the method tries to make to
that box value doesn't get you so that's
an interesting side effect we'll come
back to that one thing that's
interesting is the river
here which can help so the little screen
sort of the bottom there is using a
plug-in to resharper and Ryder
called the heap allocations viewer and
this will show you and highlights items
where things being boxed where you don't
necessarily expect it so again like with
the params issue this is something that
the compiler and the runtime are doing
for you that you don't necessarily see
as part of the language but talk about
reference types and value types well
what do I mean here let's kind of remind
ourselves really what's going on here
so the dotnet world you've basically got
two types of types two kinds of types
reference types and value types a
reference type uses the class keyword
whereas value types use the struct
keyword references are allocated on the
heap and value types are allocated on
the stack they can also be embedded
directly in a another object as well the
key difference between the two is that a
variable for a reference type is
actually a reference to the thing on the
heap so something lives on the heap and
I've got a variable and it's basically
saying it's over there when you want to
pass things around you pass it around by
that reference you pass that reference
to another method and they're called
both the caller and the called method
know that it's pointing to the same
thing over here and when you then assign
assigned to a different variable there
that variable gets a copy of the
reference and it points the same object
so you're dealing with the same object a
value type on the other hand a value
type is the actual value itself so for
an integer it's just the integer but if
you're talking like a 3d point x y&z
float values the value type there is
those three values so it's not pointing
to anything on the heap is the actual
content of the value itself this is
passed around by value so if you pass it
to another method it's a copy of it this
is important because then if you make
any modifications to that you met you're
modifying the copy not the original
value it's also important to know when
you are signing to another variable
you're making another copy so you might
be thinking you know if you if you've
got a string for example and you have s1
and s2 they're gonna be the same string
if you try to change it that example of
strings the same thing person class for
example if you
tried to change it both of those
variables would be pointing at the same
thing it would change that whereas if it
was a value type if you change one
variable the other variable is
unaffected
so heat versus tack I mentioned that
reference types are on the heap value
types are on the stack what's the
difference well the heap is its
general-purpose memory it's available
there for the lifetime of the
application and it's you allocate
something there and it lasts until it's
no longer used and the garbage collects
it cleans things up the stack though is
a block of memory for data which is
required by the method so when you enter
a method it will push space onto the
stack ready to hold all the data that's
being used for that method for all the
local variables and then where the
method exits itself the the stack is
popped and everything gets cleaned up
so stack allocation has a different
lifetime to the heap it lasts for the
lifetime of the method it's being used
in value types of the entire set of data
so if you have a value type which is the
point it's got those x y&z in there
that's the whole data that lives
directly on the stack so straight in the
stack there you've got all of the data
for your object for your the thing you
you're working with you can also use the
stack alik keyword there as well to
allocate blocks of data on the stack but
generally you don't use that one and you
just use local variables but what all
this means really is now that we've got
allocation and cleanup being cheap
because everything is just and life time
used is well-defined as well because it
lasts for the lifetime of the method but
you are limited in space you can't have
a bigger amount of objects as you can on
the heap all right back to our list over
sort of things we can easily work with
closures again another example of where
the compiler rewrites things and
introduces allocations for you that are
not perhaps very visible in your code so
if you have a closure and you're
capturing values and using them inside a
lambda what the compiler is going to do
is rewrite that until it introduces a
new class and that class is going to
contain all the captured variables or
parameters or fields and keep those
inside the class
the lambda 10 rewritten as a method on
that class so it can use that data and
work with it but now to call that it has
to allocate the class so you've got an
allocation happening there which isn't
visible when you look at the code so
link is a great example of all of this
link is very very useful it's a great
system but it's because it's using a lot
of closures it's going to hit this
problem and you gotta have allocations
that are going on there but on top of
that link is based off a lot of static
methods which then allocate in numerator
classes so there's extra allocations
going on and again the heap allocation
viewer thing can show this it can
highlight where you've got methods sorry
variables or parameters that are being
pulled into a closure class a display
class and also then when the method
itself is going to allocate something to
return back to you iterators have a
similar sort of problem here so if you
have the yield return type feature in
c-sharp iterators they also get
re-written as a state machine and
there's an allocation going on there
which the compiler does for you and you
don't necessarily see in your code a
similar thing with a sync await your
code is rewritten to a state machine
here there's an allocation for the state
machine is allocation for the task
method builder and they need on top of
that you get more allocations for the
tasks that you return back your task or
your task of T and this is generally
okay because if you have a long-running
process then you kind of need to be able
to return that you need to be able to
return something that is going to
fulfill that at some point but it also
doesn't help with some of the common use
cases so if you have a method is going
to complete synchronously rather than
asynchronously so sometimes it needs to
go off and do something for a long time
but sometimes it can say nope I've got
the answer here it is it's going to do
allocations for those those times when a
simple method return would have been
better
there's also no chance for reusing some
of those objects when you create a task
of T and you give it a value you can't
necessarily reuse that so it's just kind
of like a throwaway item which has been
allocated and the value task type which
has been introduced is very very helpful
for some of these things it is a value
type which represents the task and it's
it's great then for some of these use
cases where you want to be able to reuse
items where you also want to be able to
return synchronously without having to
allocate something and there's a really
good blog post explaining some of that
there and I've got some more links than
at the end if you want to see those okay
so those are are kind of easy things we
can fix up those are the sort of
well-known things that we can work on to
to fix up there's a bunch of ways of
working around those so we were talking
about params for example we could
introduce different overloads there with
a common number of arguments so perhaps
we usually call the method with two
parameters well create a method with two
parameters there you've got the
flexibility to call it with more in
other places but if you're frequently
calling it with to have an overload
which does that for you to work around
boxing you can introduce generic
overloads and let the the runtime work
that for you so then you don't have any
boxing there at all and if you've got
closures and avoid those in critical
paths so if you've got some code which
is called very very frequently or for a
long period of time avoid them basically
try and do something different perhaps
you can pass the state as an argument to
the lambda rather than trying to capture
it as a as a class one thing which is
going to be a nice thing to look at in
recent versions of c-sharp or local
functions because local functions have a
similar rewriting method going on but
because the scope of the call is known
most of the time it can the captured
data can be represented in a value type
that's then allocated on the stack which
again as we say is cheap to allocate
cheap to clean up and very easy and
useful to use link very similar sort of
thing there because the closures they're
avoided in critical paths we all know
how to use for each and if it might be
slightly longer code but it's going to
have a better performance characteristic
in something which is called very very
frequently iterate is an interesting one
how do you fix an iterator perhaps you
can allocate a collection and return
that perhaps that allocation is going to
be better than the allocation that the
runtime does for you
perhaps you can't allocate a collection
because you've got an infinite stream
that's going on there so you don't
really have to know it and this is one
way you kind of just have to be aware of
the cost
and then figure out a way to minimize
that for your particular use case and
then with a sink awaits
investigate value tasks right so that's
kind of some of the sort of frequently
known ways of reducing some of your
allocations there I want to look at
something which is a bit more
interesting a bit more meat to it I'm
going to have a look at reference
semantics with value types which is a
bit of a mouthful but it's all all good
stuff it's a set of features that came
in with the sort of C sharp 7 compiler
and various and following point releases
and it's a set of building blocks that
combine to produce a really nice sort of
effect but what kind of effect what am I
talking about what does this really mean
well if we have a look back at when we
talk about reference types and value
types if we talk about allocating a
reference type has a cost in terms of
garbage collection but passing around is
cheap I can pass a reference and it is
very cheap to pass around allocating of
value type is cheap because it lives on
the stack and a lifetime is determined
it can get cleaned up very easily but
then passing it around has a cost
because it gets copied
I can't necessarily modify it and there
are sort of costs associated with that
so why can't we just have the best of
both worlds why can't it be cheap to
allocate and cheap to pass around and
that's what reference semantics with
value types means basically allows us to
treat value types as though there were
reference types so we can pass by
reference anywhere so we can pass these
value types around by reference and we
get all the benefits of everything so we
get to use value types to reduce the
amount of allocations we have because
everything lives on the stack and that
then reduces our memory traffic our
garbage collections and so forth and so
on
and that then gives us better throughput
passing things by reference avoids
various copies of these value types
there and it also enables us to modify
things as well so I can instead of
passing a copy around which is a very
different thing and I can't get the
information back into it I can now
modify it and work with it
again it's important to point out that
these are low-level micro optimizations
you only need to do these in critical
paths where you have code that's being
used very very frequently and needs to
be very very fast but these kinds of
things will and are being used in the
platform they'll be used for you know
web service they'll be used in games
that we used in parsing W's and
serialization they'll be used in lots of
places you're gonna see this so it is
gonna happen if you might not
necessarily need to use it in your own
code but then again maybe you do again
profile profile profile right so what do
I mean by pass by reference and pass by
value so I've been talking about these
again now so a variable for a reference
type is a reference to the actual object
on the heap so we've got the heat we've
got the thing we're trying to create
here a person whatever it is and if I
have a variable for reference type the
variable is basically saying it's over
there it's on the heap passing this
around is very easy you just pass a
reference to the method and the called
method goes well it's that object over
there on the heap it's the same object
it knows where it is it's cheap it's
easy they see the same object but if we
have a variable for a value type it's
that the whole value itself it's our
three points in a in a in a pointing the
X Y Zed in a point passing a value type
to a method passes the whole thing and
it passes a copy of it so you've now got
two copies of the same thing assigning a
value type to a new value copies the
method as well and the original value is
unmodified so there you change one it
doesn't change the other it's also
important to point out that copies
aren't actually that expensive it's not
that much of a big deal
forget x y&z it's three items three
floats that's fine it's little block of
memory computers are very good at moving
little blocks of memory around so the
copies aren't actually that expensive
however if you are a critical path in a
very hot path then they can add up and
if you can reduce the amount of work
you're doing then that that's great okay
so let's have a look at the the first
building block out of all of this then
Co up seven introduced ref returns and
this allows us to return a reference to
a value type rather
a copy of the value so if you have a
method and you want to return something
back I want return my point back from a
method normally would be a copy of value
here I can now return a reference so
that's great the return type of the
method changes here so here are an
example of an integer this now becomes a
reference to an integer written int with
an ampersand in an eye out and it's very
important that the referent the return
type of the method changes if I'm
returning back a reference to a value
type then the thing I'm referring to the
thing I'm using must exceed the lifetime
of the called method so if I have a
value type which is a local variable
inside the method I can't pass that back
because as soon as I do the stack
disappears for that method and that
thing is gone so that that doesn't exist
so I have to pass back something which
has got a longer lifetime than like the
method that has just been called so this
has to be a field or an argument that's
been passed in but not a local variable
for similar reasons now we can't use
this with async methods because
obviously async method life time all
changes and goes a bit a bit funny so we
can't use it for a sink and we're next
to the next one yes so if we modified
the value so there is the value gets
returned back as a reference if we
modify that returned reference then we
our module it's the same as modifying
the original value because it is the
original value so we're talking about
the same thing here we haven't changed
we haven't got any copies we're
modifying the same thing you can do some
interesting things with this because I
can return now a reference to an element
inside an array and modify it in place
so I don't have to call a getter to get
the value set something up and then call
a setter to put it back in there I can
actually just change the actual thing in
place because it's a reference if the
original value it's the actual thing
there are no copies going on so there's
a lot of very interesting things you can
do along those lines to use this you
need to use the ref modifier and add
that to the the method declaration to
the return type and also in the
return statement itself I'll show you
this in a sec but we've kind of got a
problem here now because we've got a
method which has got a return type of
reference of an integer int with the
ampersand at the end of it if you want
to talk about I L and how do I assign
that to a local variable because a local
variable isn't going to be int with an
ampersand is just going to be int so um
if you assign it to if you sign a ref
return back to a new variable you're
going to get a copy which kind of
defeats the purpose because the variable
is a value type and we've just returned
a reference so see top seven also
introduced ref locals and a ref local is
a variable that is a reference to a
value type and again accessing this
variable access is the original value
they're the same thing so you use a ref
local to restore the the return value of
a referee turn and you can also use var
for this as well but you can't just use
vai you have to use 'href VAR val it's
gonna tell you well that's an int but
it's not gonna tell you that it's a
reference to an int it's just you have
to give it the ref modifier as well so
let's have a quick look at what this
looks like in practice okay so I have I
have a couple of types here I have a
struct which is a point two values an X
and a why they're public they can be
modified constructed to create them and
then I have my enemy class and my enemy
class contains a point and it has a
constructor than which creates an enemy
and gives it a location as a point I
have two methods one is to get the
current location which just returns it
this is just standard sort of code would
normally write and here I've got one
which is using ref returns and we can
heat see here now that I've got a ref
point that I'm returning back here so
I'm not ruining just a point and
returning back a reference to a point
and here I'm using return ref as part of
my keyword here so I'm returning back a
reference to the item
now I have some tests so we're going to
do some tests to make sure that the
behavior is as we expect so if we excuse
me start with the first one what we're
gonna see here is we we create an
instance of the enemy and give it a
location at X Y 10/10 and what we can do
here is we can call the get location we
get a point back if I change that value
then I'm actually working on a copy so
nothing nothing changes so I can assert
that my local copy is 12 but then the
original value if I call get location
again is still 10 so I'm working on a
copy that's no good at all I can call my
get location by ref and this will return
me back this is using the ref return
value here but I'm assigning it to just
a point and so what I get here is a copy
even though I'm calling the method by
ref and I'm calling it with the the ref
return keywords going on it's still a
copy I set it to 12 nothing changes it
got 12 and 10 going on there so what I
have to do instead is I have to use the
ref keyword when declaring my variable
as well so I have my ref VAR location
item here which is going to be just a
point but it's a reference to a point if
I change it location dot X is 12
I now confirm that I've actually updated
the value which is part of the the type
and if we run this let's just go to the
top we'll see that's everything
hopefully goes green so great now
there's one extra method down the bottom
here because you can do some kind of
weird things with this because it's a
reference I can assign things to a
reference and I can do things so what I
can actually do is assign a value to the
return value of a method which is kind
of weird don't write this in real code
because it's just confusing but yeah you
can do some fun things
okay yep all right so that's great we
can return back a reference to a value
type we can modify it and it updates the
original value and that's great and
that's lovely but the downside of this
is that we can now modify someone else's
state which is not necessarily what we
wanted to do so we've got the benefit of
being able to return something back by
reference and so we've reduced the
number of copies that are going on but
we've now got something which is mutable
and we can mutate state which we don't
necessarily want to do so we've got them
the ref read-only return feature and
this extends the ref returns and ref
locals value basically it allows you to
return a value type by reference but the
call is not allowed to modify it so the
way to use this is that you assign to
ref read-only var rather than to just
'href VAR and the compiler enforces this
read-only status with with errors
compile errors and also defensive copies
it'll actually make a copy of the code
for you I sort of the the value type for
you without you necessarily knowing so
this kind of works around a problem here
where I've got some sort of shared state
going on so for example I might create a
point which defines the origin of my
game which is at 0 0 0 I want to return
that back by reference because that's
cheaper and better and nicer and then
someone comes along and modifies that
reference and all of a sudden I've got
really weird bugs happening in my game
because somebody has changed where zero
zero zero lives and we can see this in
action as well I've got another class
very similar to the last one I've got a
struct point here again we've got public
values for x and y I've introduced a new
method here I've got this translate in
place method and here I can modify the X
and y by translating it adding values
onto X adding values onto Y and I got
two two values here for of how we can do
origin so for example I just creates a
static point which is going to be at 0 0
and I can return it back by reference
like we've just done in the previous
example and and work with that and
that's going to be a reference no copies
everything's great
and I got my second example here
second example here which is going to be
a read-only point now which again is set
to 0-0 and I've now got a static ref
read-only as part of my return type here
and if we look at how we use this then
again if I just call point of origin I'm
getting I inserting it into a standard
var so I don't have any reference stuff
going on I'm getting a copy if I make
any changes to that
then my origin is still fine
everything's good it's just like in the
previous example if I call again now
like in the previous example I call get
the origin back by reference and put it
into a reference value
I can change my origin to be 42 and X
and now I've just broken the origin and
my game is doing crazy things so that's
not good so what we do instead then is
we introduce this ref read-only var here
so I've got my read-only origin here and
in fact if I try to assign that to a
standard reference variable I get a
compile error the compiler says you
can't do this so it has to be a
read-only reference and I need to have
the reader a keyword in there and now
because it's read-only
I actually can't set a value on that so
I can't change my origin the compiler
enforces it so this is great so now I
can pass things back by reference but I
can't modify it so that's a compile
error and I got my tests there which
will just verify that everything is fine
but we now got a bit of another problem
again because you remember I had that
method translate in place so I can
actually call a method on my origin
which is read-only and it's gonna
translate it in place and that would
that should change it so that should
change my origin but it doesn't the
compiler does something for you here the
compiler goes I don't trust you you're
not necessarily doing the thing you so
think you're doing here that's supposed
to be read-only so I'm gonna make a copy
of this to call this method because I
cannot guarantee that that mess
does not change this read-only value as
we actually end up with a copy so even
though I set the value to 42 here I'm
still set at 0 at the end and if we run
these tests we'll see them that all of
those assertions hold true and we still
green on the side there so all of those
a trip and we're still good but now
we've kind of got a problem well
actually I'll come back to that next
little building block stepping away from
the ref returns rest for a sec is in
parameters so this is a method argument
modifier it kind of complements the out
and the ref keyword when you're defining
a method methods arguments and it allows
you to a pattern item a pass a value
type by reference but you're telling the
compiler that you can't modify this so
it's in only and other than that you
can't do anything with it and you have a
similar thing here the compiler will
enforce a whole bunch of safety but when
it calls a method it will make a
defensive copy and we can quickly see
that one here again we've got our
mutable points here now just to make the
point here it is mutable I've got my
translate in place which is going to
change things
I've got public value variables there so
it should be changeable it should be
mutable but now we're going to have in
fact we can assert that so if I just
create a point there mutable point
translate in place it actually does work
in it so we know that that's working now
if I have my in parameter here you can
see that I've given this method
arguments the in parameter marking we've
immediately got a compiler so you can't
do this you can't modify an in parameter
the compiler says no so that's that's
great compile time safety is even better
than runtime safety however I'm calling
my translating place which is going to
change things and I don't have a well an
error which is not great so the
something happening there which I
necessary don't necessarily want and
I've just uncommented to college
so let's see what's going on let's have
a look what I can do here is I can
create a new instance of my point pass
it into this do translate method here
and that do translate is going to have
the in modifier so we're now saying that
this particular value type is going to
be read only because it's an in
parameter I can call the translate in
place and then I can assert it and it's
going to tell me that actually that
doesn't work because it's actually reset
it back to ten originally set at ten in
the first place there so the translate
doesn't work what the compiler does
again is create a defensive copy for you
so that's great it's kept it read own it
kept it fine but we've got another copy
going on and interestingly you could
then try well perhaps I can cheat
perhaps I can pass that in parameter in
as a ref so then it becomes in out and
modifiable and all that and they
fortunately compilers thought of that it
doesn't like it and it gives you a
compile time error so you can't do that
and now if we run these tests we'll see
that all those assumptions are also true
and we're still green did that run yeah
there they are so we're still green
there and everything we've tried to do
so far is good but I gives us a bit of a
problem because we're trying to do all
these things to pass things around by
reference and it's working it's great
we've got a whole bunch of compile time
errors which is useful but if I call a
method on it I'm getting a defensive
copy well how do I stop that how do I
you know I want to try and avoid some of
these copies happening how do I avoid
that and there's another feature another
little building block which we've got
here which is the read-only struct and
this is to tell the compiler basically
that this structure is read-only it's
safe to call methods on it because it
calling a method is not going to modify
the state it's not going to mutate the
the value type itself so that makes the
the type itself immutable and this is
this is great because now all there's
going to be no copies being made
anywhere we can pass things around by
reference we can call method
we can have compile time errors and
basically we've now got the best of both
worlds and if we have a quick look at
this one we've got a read-only struct
again I've got my point class here but
I've added the the read-only keyword to
the definition so it's now a read-only
struct of points and now the compiler is
going to enforce security here so if I
have a mutable type here a mutable value
here the compiler gives me a warning and
it tells me that you can't do this it
has to be immutable so we need read-only
going on there and then that's great
because now I actually can't even write
my translate in place code because I get
errors the compiler enforces this
because it's read-only it's immutable
so that problem goes away and if we have
our value here where we try and get our
points so I've got the point going on
here again read-only reference types
being returned back if I try and use it
even if I sign it into a copy there I
try and assign something to it I can't
it's read-only it's immutable they get
compile errors and even with a reference
read-only read-only reference sorry it's
using the same object but it's it's
read-only and it's immutable I get
compile time errors and if I try and
call a method on that well I can't I
can't even define the method because
it's immutable so it's no good so it's
not even worth running those tests
because I can't compile so this is great
more efficient got no copies made when
calling members we can pass things
around without calling members and this
is great for throughput performance and
so on but again this is these are all
sort of micro optimizations but they can
add up in critical code paths the other
key thing here is that there are no
changes to the CLR so all of these
features have been added just to the
language this has already been this has
been previously supported by the CLR all
along and I was just exposed by c-sharp
so we can make use of this anywhere and
everywhere alright one last building
block which is really useful here this
is this is one which looks odd on the
face of it
but he's really useful come back to it
shortly this is a ref struct this is the
ability to declare a value type that can
only be stacked allocated you can't
allocate it anywhere else you can't
embed it as part of another object so
you couldn't have a person which
contains one of these ref structs and
you can only allocate it understand the
stack so this constrains the lifetime of
these value types it also means they
can't be boxed they can't use them
inside another struct if that struct is
not also a ref struct I can't use it
with async methods or iterators can't be
users of generic parameters there's a
whole bunch of limitations to it it
doesn't really kind of make sense as to
why you would do that and there are very
limited to use cases for this so one of
which is using stack alec and that's
just a way of allocating a block of
memory on your stack but the big reason
is for span of T which is a new type
which has been around it's actually run
for a little while but it's it's a very
useful type which is all about reducing
the amount of allocations you get and
this is where things start to get useful
for you as an application developer so
span of T is it's a new type really to
unify working with any kind of
contiguous memory any block of of memory
so if you've got like a nice big block
of memory like an array or a string
which is using one long self-contained
block of memory it's really useful for
working with that also useful for
working with array segments so chunks of
an array or sub strings also good for
native memory and for memory allocated
on the stack with a stack our keyword
and basically it provides an array like
API for working with this this block of
memory so it looks like indexes
basically you've got a get and a set
you've got the index over the square
brackets you've got you know getting set
methods and so on and there's also a
read-only span of T type which is
read-only and you've only got getters
it's also type safe so each element in
this array this block of memory which
you're going to start treating like an
array
is typesafe it is an instance of tea so
if you have a span of bite then each
element in there is gonna be a bite if
you have a span of point Ito into that
is going to be a point structure and the
nice thing about this is that you get
array like performance so it's not quite
as fast as an array but it's really
close and the newer runtimes have
special support built into this to make
it really close so it is it's very good
this is a great way of working with
blocks of memory like arrays and have
the same sort of performance and api's
as arrays but one of the key things one
of the really really useful things the
span of tea is is slicing you can create
a new span of tea which is a subsection
of an existing span so if you're talking
like you've got a block of memory which
is going to be a string you can get a
substring out of that by pulling out a
span which is just that section there
and all of this is without allocations
so if we're talking the saying that it's
without allocations that means it's a
value type yes it is it's great it's
available as a new get package for donek
standard 1.1 which means Donna frame at
4.5 and above it's built into the lost
track if it's built into the darknet
standard it's built into dotnet core 2.1
and above i think it's in the standard I
forget now but there's also a whole load
of new api's and overloads for working
with with span so you can convert a
string to a span or you can have streams
that return as it's a return but a block
of an array of bytes you can return a
span and also then for parsing blocks of
text so utf-8 powers of converting a
string into into utf-8 text and the
whole point of this is that makes a huge
amount of use of all the ref semantics
stuff we've just been talking about to
get a whole load of allocation free
stuff going through and it's really a
handful of types we've got span of T
read-only span of T which we've already
mentioned there's also memory of T which
is a interesting one it allows you to
work with
I work around the user so the
limitations of span of t being a struct
and I'll talk a bit more out in a sec
they're also two versions so on more
downlevel versions of the dotnet
framework then there are there's a
portable version and then there is
effectively a fast version the fast
version requires runtime support but
it's kind of important to say really
that the portable version is not slow
you get it's not as fast as a raise but
it's still good so it's just as portable
doesn't mean it's slow so this works on
donna framework 4.5 and above as part of
the donít standard 1.1 which is old now
and with dotnet core 3 and dotnet 5
could mean anything but the the
implementation of this one really is
that this span of T has three fields you
have the object reference to the big
block of memory you have an internal
offset for where it starts and in the
length so you know where it is there so
this is actually slightly larger than
the fast version but the difference is
like slightly there so dereferencing
values is slightly more complex because
you got to go to the start add on the
offset and then work with that but
that's fine and easy the fast
implementation requires runtime support
and this is a dotnet core 2.1 and above
and the runtime recognizes this type
this only has two fields it has a
special by ref internal pointer so
you've got this block of memory and the
span says I start there so it doesn't
have to start the beginning account it
knows exactly where to start
and it knows the length which means
thing getting at the values is slightly
faster slightly simpler and and
therefore slightly better performance
but more importantly the runtime knows
this type and it has specific
optimizations in the dips to get rid of
a few things
in the same way it does with arrays so
for example when working with arrays the
runtime the Donette frame at runtime
direct core runtime recognizes that
you're iterating over an array and it
gets rid of the bounds checks for each
array access
so he knows you're going from 1 to 10
and he doesn't have to do a bounced
check on every single one of those the
run time can do the same thing for span
of T and that then gives you very very
close to array like performance so what
does this have to do with ref structs I
was talking about that and as building
blocks and all this where does all that
fit in well because we've got these
these fields inside the span of T we
kind of have to update everything all at
once for thread safety so we have to do
all sort of atomically if we only did
one part of the the thing without doing
the other we would break a be horrible
and nasty and the whole point of this
type is performance so we can't put
locks and synchronization around it
there because that defeats the purpose
there are other reasons as well is that
this by ref pointer into the middle of
an object requires special tracking
inside the garbage collector having too
many of those on the go at any time can
get expensive but if you reduce the
amount of them then it's manageable
also if you want span of T to allocate
to represent a whole bunch of different
types of memory from strings to arrays
to native memory to stack allocating
memory how does it deal with stack
allocated memory if span atif was a
class and lived on the heap because
stack allocated memory only has a
constrained lifetime and the answer to
all of those questions really is that
span of T is a ref struct and by putting
all those constraints which we had for
refs trucks on span of T you fix all of
those problems it can only be created on
the stack so you don't have to worry
about thread safety anymore because on
the stack it can only be called from one
method you can't pass it around because
it's it's it's got constrained access
and you don't have to worry about the
number of garbage plates and a garbage
collector handles going on there as well
because you're only gonna have a limited
number of those thanks to the core stack
okay so let's have a quick look at this
so I have another set of tests here of
using this now I've got this added as a
as a new get package so I've got my
packages there I have
oh no sorry I'm using this is a dotnet
kora have I forgot yes I was done in
collab so it's part of the.net core API
itself and so I'm just using that and I
get to use my string dot as span so I've
got extension method here which is going
to convert my string which is a constant
defined at the top of the class there
convert into a span and I sign it here
now to a read-only span of char and from
here I can do a bunch of things that you
would normally expect to do with with
strings basically I can treat it in the
same way I can check the span of the
spans length is correct I can do
equality with another string so I can do
string comparisons based on this span
comparing it to another string and I can
do that string comparison with the same
sort of invariant culture ignoring case
and so on because thanks to these
extension methods I can even do things
like starts with make sure that it's it
starts with the appropriate values I've
got another test now which will create a
slice so again one of the benefits of
having span in fact the best benefit of
it is being able to slice and pull data
out without having to allocate anything
and so if I call slice of six there I
can then confirm with a call to equals
that have actually got a value here
which is what I would expect and I can
do a similar sort of thing here with
arrays as well so I have my numbers
array at the top here it's just a set of
arrays of one to ten I can create a span
out of that I don't have to call as span
here there's an implicit conversion so
that's nice I can just treat an array as
a span without having to do anything I
can then slice it I can start at three
and go forever for length of five and if
I change that element there inside my
slice I can then confirm that actually
it's going to be this value here inside
the main array and so if I run these
tests we should see then that's again
those assumptions will go green and then
the best thing is that it's all
allocation free as well so I've got
another test here which is first of all
getting the current amount of memory
I then make sure that I'm not allowed to
do any garbage collection inside this
area I call all of those tests
explicitly and then I just assert that
zero memory was allocated there there
was no change there I I change there so
this is kind like a very crude way of
checking to see that there's no
allocations happening at that point and
so we can see now that we can do all of
these things create slices and change
values and all of that without
allocating any extra memory all right so
that's great span of T is is really
useful and I can probably see a number
of useful ways of doing that and what
about some of real-world usage is from
something else very handily a couple of
days ago Microsoft announced a preview
of system text Jason this is a new
library which they're using which
they're introducing to do Jason series
ation and deserialization for the.net
platform this is to effectively
decoupled Jason net from the platform
because if the problem is the platform
currently relies on Jason net and it
relies in a particular version of Jason
net which means that you can't update it
without updating your platform and your
application version this mismatch and so
if there's problems there they also want
something which is better from a
performance point of view you know
making use of some of these new API s
and and so basically they've introduced
a new a new library so the whole point
of this is that it uses as part of what
it does it uses span of T to be able to
to work with things be able to parse
things without having to introduce a
whole load of new allocations and it's
optimized for the things you'd expect to
use Jason for in in real life and web
service and generally you'll work with
utf-8 rather than utf-16 which is the
actual encoding that the string type
uses and so normally you would have to
read everything in convert it to utf-16
and work on that but what system text
Jason can do is read in a set of bytes
from the file treat those as utf-8 right
over by putting it all into one big span
and work with that span to
things and match things and get data
without allocating anything they're
having to allocate any strings this is
going to be part of dotnet core 3 and
right now there is a preview NuGet
package which you can download and try
and use the blog post which they have
has some micro benchmarks against Jason
net and you can see here now where these
kinds of things can start really pay off
so in the the benchmarks that they've
used there so deserialization can be two
times faster because of reduce of better
throughput basically see rosette
serialization can also be faster but
getting at the document using the
document object model writing and
reading these can actually be more or
less allocation free and the more or
less is because the way that they've
implemented things is that there are
some allocations happening so for
example when you read data in you have
to put it into a byte array but some of
these things are pulled an object pulled
so if you ignore the overhead of the
those pools for the object arrays sorry
the byte arrays then you don't get any
actual allocations for the objects
themselves until you then try so for
example you read it you want to get a
string value out that will then allocate
you a string and again you can see now
where this throughput really helps with
again from the blog post from the other
day talking about Jason D serialization
and serialization you can see the
requests per second figures for the
difference between Jason nets and system
text Jason you're actually getting a
real-world improvements there you're
getting better
requests / responses per second memory
usage is is not so dramatically
different but the actual the throughput
itself is and we can have a very quick
look that's something here so if we have
a little bit of code here for example we
can parse the value here before you pass
in a string we can parse that and pull
that out into adjacent document so now
can I got a Dom value here I can then
have that will allocate that's going to
allocate my byte array to read the
values it's gonna have some allocations
going on there those allocations are
pulled so we're making use of the sort
of the object reuse which we're talking
previously with the low-hanging fruit
stuff and but now if I wanted to
enumerate that object model I can use
this enumerate array value and have a
look at how that works if I go to the
type of that we can see that's let me do
that again sorry so if you go to
enumerate array we see that that returns
back an array in numerator which is a
struct so this is great I'm going to
return back in a numerator which is a
struct so there's not gonna be much
allocations going on there and if we
have a look at jason element here we see
that that is also a struct so we're
working with value types and having to
we're avoiding allocations going on here
if I very quickly step in to get
property and try get property we then
see that we're converting this into a
spam so we get the looking for a
particular property with a name which is
a string we convert that into a spam and
when we passed it this in here let's see
if we can find the right bit of code no
that's the wrong bit of code we're
working with spans there so we get to
use those spans going on internally if
we have a look at the getting an integer
and if we step into that a couple of
times cause gets which finally calls
this we can see here that what we're
doing to get the actual value is that we
are finding out where this particular
property lives with a location and a
length and then we use a slice on the
original string that we've got to get
that particular bit of text there so
we're using slices to get at the value
which we can then decode and return back
and because this is returning back an
integer value then we're going to be
able to do all of that without allocate
anything which is pretty nifty so yes so
that entire loop there won't allocate
anything which is very nice so I can
work with a document object model
without allocations which brings me to
the end so then that really is
everything that I wanted to show you
there's a reasons for wanting to reduce
the number of allocations we do is all
about throughput all about reducing the
amount of memory we're using the amount
of memory traffic that's happening so
that we can reduce the number of garbage
collections improve throughput and
hopefully then that will improve
performance for us as well
key thing is profiling these are all
micro optimizations but they can't have
a very big impact as we saw with the the
benchmarks therefore the responses for a
second and there are a number of ways of
doing this that we obviously look at
some of the low-hanging fruit there but
there's also a number of interesting
building blocks with value types passing
those around by reference and being able
to enforce safety of making them
immutable and so we can't change them
and working with that that code there
and finally span of takes parity is
really really useful and something that
you are likely to use in your own code
if you need to do any kind of pausing or
serialization yourself and to be able to
get it data there without how to
allocate anything these are some very
useful links which have details about it
there so the first one is Microsoft's
documentation for this features these
features which explains what's going on
with the reference semantics more detail
about the span of T some really good
sort of blog post there explaining how
span of T works how the runtime has
optimizations for it and then also
there's a great post on how value tasks
works and when and why you would want to
use it there there are some really good
use cases for avoiding allocating tasks
and task of T and using value tasks
instead and finally there's the system
text JSON blog post from a few days ago
there which is describing this new API
and some of the details around out and
finally if you want to get some of the
the test always running today the sample
code there is
up on github in the top right hand
corner I think probably out of time
there if anybody has any questions and
please feel free to come down and and
ask also be at the JetBrains booth so if
you want to pop by and say hello then
feel free and please don't forget about
the feedback cards on the way out
other than that thank you very much
[Applause]